これは・・・
僕と・・・
後輩と・・・
カメラマンの・・・
3人の日常を撮った動画です。
はじめ：ナイス！
まさき：ナイス
まさき：あ、結構いいんじゃない？
はじめ：かう、完全に勝ちだよこれ
まさき：あうっ
はじめ：このステージは勝てた。
はじめ：ハイ今日のセカンドチューンは、あ待って・・・
はじめ：日常です、はいっ。
はじめ：まさきはオネェだった
まさき：うおぉい
まさき：変なタイミングでスプラトゥーンブーム来ちゃったね
はじめ：当たる当たる当たる・・・
はじめ：うわっ！すごい！
はじめ：すごいきゅ・・・
はじめ：うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁい！
はじめ：うっ、ううううううう！
はじめ：うおおおおおおおおおお！！
はじめ：うおおおおおおおおおおおおおお!!(# ﾟДﾟ)
はじめ：ういいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいい！！
はじめ：ううぇ？なんとか･･･え、上手すぎる・・・
はじめ：それはまずい･･･
はじめ：うえええええええ！ええええええ！
バンバンバン！
はじめ：え、かったべ？でも・・・
まさき：へへへへwwwww
まさき：サイコパスじゃん、マジで。(犯罪係数：341
はじめ：全てそっからだよ。こんなことやってる場合じゃない
遊戯王しよう。
はじめ：くるんだってよ。
まさき：そーなんだぁ。
はじめ：電気がもったいない。
はじめ：偉い
カメラマン：電気がもったいないｗｗ
まさき：今までそんなこと言ったこと一度もなかったのにｗ
はじめ：やめてよｗｗ
はじめ：すげー日常動画だよ
まさき：ふぅん
カメラマン：ハハハｗｗ
はじめ：最初はグー、じゃんけんぽんっやべっ
まさき：先攻っ！
はじめ：あい
はじめ：違う！
カメラマン(？)：後攻いただきまーす
まさき：ウィンターベル(遊戯王のカード)で
まさき：ウィンターベルの効果
まさき：墓地のＷＷ(ワラワラ)選択して･･･
まさき：うわぁ、つえぇｗｗ
(どうやらはじめんの睨むはバツグンだったようだ！)
まさき：６００ダメージ
はじめ：うわっ！？
まさき：えっ？？(困惑
はじめ：えっなに・・・？
はじめ：は？(´･ω･｀)
はじめ：どんどん言ってない？　下
(三人はどうやら混乱で言語を忘れてしまったようだ！)
はじめ：え、マジで動きたくないんだけど
カメラマン：えっ、まっ･･･
カメラマン：え？とりあえず何？
カメラマン：これはなに？
カメラマン：おちた？
はじめ：ブレーカーが落ちてるね。多分
まさき：うん
はじめ：バチンッっていったから
カメラマン：え、どうすんの
はじめ：パソコンつけてたぁ？
はじめ：切ってる？
カメラマン：切ってある
はじめ：え、ヤバいね
カメラマン：え、さ、三人で･･･
はじめ：これちがうよね
はじめ：はぃというわけで
はじめ：え？まって、マジでこわいんﾀﾞｹﾄﾞ（びくびく
はじめ：一先ず、ブレーカー戻すかぁ･･･
まさき：うん
カメラマン：ブレーカーどこにあんの？
はじめ：やべっ全然笑えねぇんだけど
はじめ：たぶん下？
カメラマン：何処にある？
はじめ下にある2階にある
はじめ：え、まって
はじめ：誰かいたってことでしょぉ？
はじめ：ｻｲｼｮﾊｸﾞｰｼﾞｬﾝｹﾝﾎﾟﾝ
はじめ：行きましょうか･･･
はじめ：え、でもこれ
はじめ：メインチャンネルで上げるよワンチャン
まさき：(苦笑)
はじめ：メインチャンネル上げるよ
カメラマン：え、な、何かあったらどうすんの？これ
カメラマン：怖くね？
カメラマン：なんかあれ･･･パラノーマル(漫画)みたいなのににありそうじゃん
はじめ：(苦笑)
カメラマン：やだぁ･･･
はじめ：行きます
はじめ：え、まさき、何かあったら助けて
カメラマン：どうすればいいんだよ･･･俺一番後ろか？
まさき：間の方がよくね？
こんこっこんこっここん
はじめ：ほんっとにこわい、マジでこわいこわいこわ
はじめ：付かねぇわ･･･
はじめ：すいませ～ん
こんこっこん
はじめ：すいませ～～(´◉◞౪◟◉)
はじめ：ﾅﾝｶｵﾄｼﾅｶｯﾀ･･･?
まさき：シテタヨｗｗ
カメラマンちょちょちょぷしーｗｗ
はじめ：うわぁお！
まさき：うおぉ！　ビックリしたぁ･･･ねぇ
はじめ：ウハハハｗｗ
まさき：え～本当にやめて（真面目
はじめ：あ、でもちょっとまって
はじめ：でも鍵あいてるからヤッパリ（ドヤァ
まさき：しめとこ
カメラマン：しめしめとりあえずしめよ
はじめ：え、でも中にいたらどうすんの
カメラマン：え、でも、怖いの。それはそれで･･･
まさき：大丈夫だよねぇ･･･
まさき：でぇ、電気付けてぇ
まさき：見よう！
はじめ：周りになんか･･･全体てきなアレ(停電)ではない。
まさき：え、とりあえずブレーカー上げようよ
カメラマン：え、だってあれ、付いてるよねぇ？
まさき：ここぉ？
はじめ：この家だけだよ
まさき：これは別じゃない？
カメラマン：この家だけだよねぇ？
はじめ：うぅうぅうぅうぅ～
まさき：これじゃない？
はじめ：うああああああっ！
まさき：うわっ、ビックリした･･･
はじめ：直った･･･
はじめ：え、待って！スプラトゥーン付けっぱだったんだけど！
まさき：消えた？
はじめ：死んでる死んでる死んでる･･･
まさき：なんでぇ？
はじめ：え、でも絶対誰か入ってたよ
まさき：え、ドッキリ･･･じゃないの？
カメラマン：うえぇ？
はじめ：でも普通ドッキリだったら２カメ回すよ。俺、今、多分
まさき：確かに･･･
カメラマン：切る？(半泣き)
はじめ：一回切っとくかぁ･･･
カメラマン：切ろう･･･
はじめ：ブレーカーが急に落ちてしまいました･･･
はじめ；なんか多分物音がしたんでぇ･･･
はじめ：分かんない。何が原因か全く分かんない
はじめ：なんかいた？
カメラマン：わかんないっす･･･
はじめ：あ、デュエルの続きだ
まさき：えっ、えっ、ホントに･･･
はじめ：一先ずデュエルを終わらせます
はじめ：え、何だったの？マジで
まさき：ねぇ、これデュエルに集中出来ない･･･
はじめ：何でもないよぉー
はじめ：スタンバイ！
まさき：はい
はじめ：戻ってきます
ﾄﾞﾝｯ！(物音)
はじめ：完全になんか落ちた今の･･･
まさき：なんか？
はじめ：じゃない？
はじめ：外？
はじめ：中だった気がする。でも･･･
カメラマン：よく行けるね･･･
まさき：え、どうすんの？これ
カメラマン：え、俺カメラマンだから･･･
はじめ：誰もいないよ？でも
まさき：大丈夫？
カメラマン：で、電気付けて･･･
はじめ：クローゼットだよ。でも、後は･･･
はじめ：えー、でも、いないでしょさすがに。
はじめ：行きます！
まさき：うあっ！うあああっ！
はじめ：はい、という訳で今からまさきが来るんですけどもぉ･･･
はじめ：これは、サブチャン(ネル)っていう体(てい)で取るでしょ？
はじめ：一先ず、まぁ遊戯王するでしょ？
はじめ：ペンデュラム召喚！
まさき：ふふふふふふふ
はじめ：四体！
はじめ：作戦はじゃぁ、こっちから送るよ
まさき：完全にミスった
はじめ：えっ！？
はじめ：ドアドン！とかしたり
ﾄﾞﾝｯ！
はじめ：右側の様子はここでカメラで撮ってほしい
まさき：なんでなんでなんでぇ？
はじめ：ヤバイヤバイヤバイヤバイ
はじめ：したらここで構えてもらいます
はじめ：ブレイカ―落とす。バーンって
まさき：うおっ！？
はじめ：えっ？
まさき：もう何にも信じないよ俺
はじめ：落ちついてまさき
カメラマン：グフッ(笑)